alors vous avez vu des gens un peu
partout stéphane bédard devant tendu
donc ces témoignages de citoyens
rencontrés vous avez été réélus pour une
sixième fois dans chicoutimi bonsoir
stéphane bédard bon droit est-ce que
vous dans les derniers jours vous
sentiez qu'il y avait quelque chose
vraiment qu'ils aillent qu'elle n'est
pas là non effectivement ça a été une
dure campagne les derniers jours ont été
particulièrement difficiles ça a été
difficile de trouver des thèmes
tellement que je posais la question ce
matin un journaliste quel est
l'engagement principal du parti libéral
et il était incapable de me répondre
simplement parce que
cette campagne a été monopolisée par
autre chose et ça fait en sorte ça a été
très difficile et sur la fin ce qui
restait c'était pas grand chose c'était
très dur de percevoir le l'opinion
populaire on sentait qu'il y avait un
glissement
et donc on parle de ces résultats là
c'est sur moi quand je continue c'est
sûr qu'il faut que je te remercie
allégeant de m'avoir fait confiance mais
plusieurs de mes collègues qui avait
bien du mérite
ont eu à affronter
malheureusement des défaites des fois
très serré mais des effets vous l'avez
mentionné dans charlevoix madame madame
marois elle même bord du a
cédé circonscription ou même avec le
scénario d'une élection d'un
gouvernement libéral vous pensiez garder
ces circonscriptions là on avait on n'a
pas anticipé le scénario qu'on vit
actuellement est par contre ce qui est
positif c'est qu'on est une équipe qui
est quand même ça l'est déjà vu sur 30
députés il ya des éléments d'expérience
et il ya des du renouveau il ya même eu
une seule nouvelle dans le 2 e mail me
diane del mar et pierre karl péladeau on
est quand même des gens d'expérience
bernard drainville oui il ya des gens de
grand talent sylvain gaudreault donc au
moins il ya un noyau qui est solide et
qui font en sorte qu' on peut entrevoir
l'avenir avec en disant il faut
maintenant continuer à rebâtir et c'est
ce qu'on va faire dans l'image je vous
trouve très optimiste monsieur bédard
j'aimerais vous entendre sur le post
mortem sur l'objet de la réflexion il ya
eu commençons par
cette question sur le référendum qui
revenu vous hanter il ya des gens qui
disent aujourd'hui dans le fond pourquoi
le parti québécois parle pas plus
franchement de la souveraineté quitte à
réduire les intentions de vote il y
aurait une clarté que vous en pensez
bien et regardait ce qui était en un
mois ça fait j'ai 46 ans j'ai passé
toute ma vie d'un parti souverainiste il
s'était lui plusieurs gouvernements et
souverainistes ce qui est étonnant c'est
que pendant campagne tout d'un coup la
date du référendum est plus importante
que l'idéal mais c'est ce qui est
problématique c'est tellement à trouver
des solutions mais c'est quand même
incroyable qu'on est passé six jours à
se demander quand serait le référendum
alors que moi ce que nous on souhaite
c'est faire du québec un pays quand même
c'est pas une date et on voit que
pendant la campagne autant j'aurais un
discours sur l'avenir du québec dans les
prochaines semaines où je verrai
personnes et il y aurait pas d'intérêt
autant pendant la campagne ça devient un
sujet à peu près le seul sujet d'intérêt
et là ça a été le seul sujet pendant
mais ce dont vous savez puis votre père
dans une autre période connue aussi ce
ces déchirements là est ce qu'on met pas
de côté mon et l'option voyant que les
québécois n'en veulent pas pour
l'instant
rené lévesque le faire en 1981 en
parlant du beau risque on a vu la suite
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas une réflexion
profonde sur la stratégie là-dessus
modja de la stratégie sur qu'est ce
qu'on présente aux québécois qu'est ce
qu'on présente oui effectivement il ya
une réflexion je pense tout le monde
doit faire une petite réflexion aussi
sur le type de campagne connu où ça a
été très difficile même de montrer le
chef pas le chef je voudrais sont le but
pour nous beaucoup les chefs mais où on
ne peut être contenue mais effectivement
là dessus ce qui est important monsieur
lévesque en 82 souvenez vous c'était
suite au référendum de 80 et à
l'élection de 2,81
ce conte à se positionner c'est comme on
le présente et surtout se dire que la
division actuellement du vote
souverainiste est pas bonne pour
personne et on joue en cause et
messieurs je vous ai dit c'est de ma
faute là je vous posais la question plus
précisément est-ce que vous pensez que
vous devez poser sur l'accélérateur en
parler plus de façon plus ouverts
monsieur landry gc aujourd'hui tel qu'on
devrait il devra en parler plus en
reparler quitte à avoir des résultats
difficiles - il y aura une clarté là
dedans ou au contraire mettre de côté
l'option qu'elle voit vous privilégiez
vous
vous savez le parti québécois est un
parti qui appartient aux mains c'est un
parti qui a le plus de membres donc aux
gens décider mais plus en parler oui
mais que lille vous désirez la
réverbération où la couverture de cela
si demain matin je fais un grand
discours emporté sur l'importance de
faire du québec un pays dans le contexte
international
j'aurais pas de couverture c'est ça qui
est étonnant c'est un peu ccaf colle à
l'envers dans le sens que si on n'en
parle plus lors de la campagne
électorale quelles vont être les
résultats réels et c'est ça qui fait que
une campagne devient évidemment c'est un
moment qui est très condensée mais ce
sujet l'art vielles comme s'il était
nouveau à chaque fois or est ce qu on
vous sent peut-être mal à l'aise avec ce
sujet là on sent que c'est pas clair que
madame marois marcher sur un fil il ya
des gens qui dans le parti peut-être
proposer de dire aux québécois y en aura
pas de référendum dans le prochain
mandat mais elle n'a pas voulu aller
aussi loin ça aurait pu être une option
c'est tout ce dont vous allez parler au
cours des prochains jours non bon on va
parler de ça mais oui vous savez il faut
se dire en même temps qu'une élection ça
sera jamais un référendum et je serai
bien content de vous dire que si le
parti québécois est élu il va avoir un
pays dans demain c'est pas le cas ce qui
est étonnant c'est que le principe d'une
campagne électorale ça reste quand même
d'élire un gouvernement que dans son
programme entre autres oui
peut-être ça mais qui a entre autres
bien d'autres choses qui est celle de
gouverner comment gouverner c'est quand
même étonnant que le cadre financier
retenu si peu d'attention mais que la
date du référendum et elle est réussie a
persisté pendant six jours consécutifs
hélas ce n'est pas la faute sur personne
ce que je constate c'est même ce qui est
évident retient peu la tension et ça
laisse pas beaucoup de choix à
l'auditeur ou à la personne qui veut se
faire une opinion sur quel est le
meilleur gouvernement comment vous vous
êtes senti en terminant monsieur mis
d'accord vous avez vu hier pierre karl
péladeau jean françois lisée bernard
drainville dire un pays un pays
maintenant avez vous pas eu l'impression
comme plusieurs gens qui nous ont parlé
qu'à 20 des connexions lentes les
électeurs à dire une chose puis je
disais exactement le contraire je pense
qu'il s'attendait pas à être sur la tv
nationale
au même moment
je me suis informé un peu comment c'est
arrivé effectivement c'est pas le
meilleur choix qu'ont eue mais dans les
faits ça leur part leur appartenait peut
on leur a demandé de vous dire est de
motiver les gens qui étaient dans la
salle est bon le résultat je peux vous
dire c'est pas celui qu'on s'attende m
sur l'offre éventuellement raison je
pense que lui-même en sont conscients il
y avait des gens qui vivaient quand même
une période électorale qui était traité
une campagne difficile donc on va
arrêter de vous torturer serait
prolongée si vous n'êtes que buvry 10
secondes est-ce que vous souhaitez une
course à la direction rapides ou prendre
le temps de gérer tout seul on on a le
temps je pense que les québécois ans et
a tant entendu parler d'élections
l'important panser nos plaies regardez
l'équipe regarder l'avenir reconstruire
puis plus tard effectivement tenir cette
course mais pas à court terme je pense
qu'on a du temps devant ses fans bellard
élue pour la sixième fois dans
chicoutimi merci nous avons parlé au
lendemain de cette élection extrêmement
difficile pour votre parti merci merci
merci aux gens de chicoutimi outils au
revoir avant